foreign
[Music]
the sitting is open the court meets
today to hear the first round of oral
argument of the Russian Federation for
reasons Dooley made known to me judge
Abraham is unable to be present on the
bench today I now give the floor to his
Excellency Mr Alexander's vase Shogun
agent of the Russian Federation you have
the floor Excellency
foreign
president
distinguished members of the Court
it is for me a great honor and a
privilege
to appear before this court on behalf of
the Russian Federation
Russia has tremendous respect for the
international court of justice
as the principal judicial organ of the
United Nations
and which represents
different
legal traditions and systems from around
the world
Russia accounts on the peaceful
settlement of disputes in accordance
with the United Nations Charter
including
through a fair and impartial judicial
procedure
firmly convinced that Justice must be
rendered openly
and independently of political
considerations
indeed
truth must be expressed
for justice to be done
it is in this spirit that my country
has
engaged in good faith in these judicial
proceedings concerning
two major multilateral conventions
the International Convention for the
suppression of the financing of
terrorism
icsft and the International Convention
on the elimination of all forms of
racial discrimination
cerd
unfortunately
isn't it is not always easy to establish
the truth
today
in the information era
truth sometimes seems to be obvious and
easily accessible whereas in actual fact
it is
clouded by a political fog created by
information campaigns that are
propagated and dominated
by the most powerful states and media
companies
this makes the judicial task even more
difficult than it was before
Madam president distinguished members of
the Court
We Have Heard
the applicant during these hearings
and we have no doubts as to its desire
to assume the role of accuser
while trying to set itself
forward as a protector of the peoples of
the Crimea against discrimination while
accusing the Donetsk and lugansk
people's republics of being a terrorist
organization supposedly financed by
Russia
nothing however could be further removed
from the truth
Kiev has no moral Authority allowing it
to put forward such accusations
that regime came to power following a
violent coup d'etat in 2014 they arrived
on the shoulders of nationalists the
direct descendants of Nazi Collaborators
from the Second World War
the current Ukrainian government
openly acclaims and celebrates
Nazi war criminals as Ukrainian Heroes
the Neo-Nazi groups
on Whose shoulders the current Kiev
regime rests began by encouraging the
armed revolts in Western Ukraine
and this was well before the events that
occurred in the east
they continued with the violence at the
maidan in Kiev
the effect of which was to overturn both
the president and the legitimate
government of Ukraine
as a result a new government of Victors
in inverted Commerce and
including neo-nazis leaders of the
maidan and their collaborators in key
positions in charge of the Armed Forces
the police and propaganda
came to power
they continued to spread Terror
throughout the entire country
killing opposition leaders
politicians
journalists and ordinary citizens
who quite simply dared to express their
disagreement
anyone who
opposed mainly in the Eastern regions in
the dunbas the answer given to these was
a
massive armed attack by the regime and
at the same time that same regime
qualified them as terrorists in order to
justify such brutal repression
for a period of seven years since the
spring of 2014
that regime has decimated donbass
shelling bombing and daily killings have
caused thousands of deaths and thousands
of civilians injured many of whom were
children
the soldiers from Kiev and the Neo-Nazi
battalions
have used civilians as human Shields in
order to protect themselves against the
reprisals of the donbass forces
what Ukraine is now seeking is a
decision by your court
that would allow it to treat
the citizens of donbass who are fighting
for survival as in inverted commas equal
to terrorists
but it is clear it is generally
acknowledged that the situation in
donbass
was a bloody armed conflict between the
Kiev regime and the donuts and luhans
Republics
a conflict governed by humanitarian law
aside from Ukraine
nobody has ever
considered that these republics were
terrorist organizations
Madam president
distinguished members of the Court
at the provisional measures stage
the court
found that the arguments of Ukraine
concerning the financing of terrorism
were not plausible
given that Ukraine failed in
demonstrating failed to demonstrate that
the acts that it was referring to
could even be considered as offenses
within the meaning of Article 2 of the
icsft
at the judicial stage and at the stage
of admissibility
the court decided to postpone its
examination of
the main arguments of Russia as to the
merits in particular those concerning
intention and knowledge
today we are going to show you how
Ukraine's claims are not just
implausible
what is more
they are based on flawed
into interpretations of law and
contradict even
Elementary Common Sense and they are
based either on fake factual evidence or
contradict Ukraine's own position
the same can be said of Ukraine's
allegations
concerning a so-called systemic campaign
of racial discrimination I quote
against the ukrainians and tatars of
Crimea
Ukraine has committed violations of
crimeans Rights and this has been
recorded over a period of years
nonetheless sets itself up as it as
they're protector today
it is all the more hypocritical because
the Kiev together with the merge list
has established a blockade of Crimea
cutting off the peninsula from access to
water food electricity
medication and other Essentials to the
detriment of the population
what is more the members of the match
list
set off bombs in order to destroy the
energy lines leading to Crimea
thus depriving the entire population of
Crimea of electricity
Ukraine is now
looking for Flaws in the educational
system of Crimea
while approving the ban not only on
education in the Russian language Beyond
elementary school but also use of the
Russian language in the media and in
public life
notwithstanding the fact that the
Russian language in Ukraine
contrary to the Ukrainian language in
Crimea
is a language in daily use for the
majority of the population
the actions taken by the regime in kieva
contrary to the legal effervescence
of its Council
a show that our opponents have no real
interest in the well-being of crimeans
nor
for the struggle against their so-called
and I quote discrimination
kiev's real objective is not to fight
against discrimination
but to challenge the status of Crimea
which is not at issue in this case as
the court itself affirmed in its
Judgment of 2019.
Ukraine
shows similar bad faith in the case of
donbass
there too it was not interested in a
peaceful solution
the Minsk agreements were based on the
idea of a return
of dunbas under the control of Ukraine
while respecting the desire of the
donbass population to enjoy broader
autonomy
it transpires today according to the
former Ukrainian French and German
leaders who signed or guaranteed
these Minsk agreements that
their only real purpose was to give
Ukraine time to arm itself for a
military solution to the donbass
question
unfortunately Kiev never intended to
respect these agreements it's only
objective was to
conquer dombas by force
kiev's actions
ultimately
pushed the Donetsk and lugansk people's
republics into invoking their right to
self-determination and legitimate
defense including Collective legitimate
defense in accordance with the
provisions of the United Nations Charter
and international customary law
of course this case does not concern the
most recent events
in fact
it only concerns the events that
occurred between 2014 and 2017.
nonetheless
as Ukraine's agent
has focused so much on this aspect I
will say that it is Ukraine which
rejected the Minsk agreements and began
the violence against Don Bass
it is Ukraine which refused
any negotiated solution
and announced its desire and I quote to
win on the battlefield
end of quotation
it is the Ukrainian senior officials who
called
people to and I quote kill all Russians
kill them everywhere end of quotation
they began by killing journalists and
political activists not just in Ukraine
but also in Russia
Ukraine is constantly turning to
propaganda
blatant lies
and false accusations leveled against
the Russian Federation even before this
court
on the very the first day of the hearing
Ukraine's agent
stated and I quote
today
Russia was behind the destruction of a
large Dam at novakovka end of quotation
in fact
this was done by Ukraine
the Kiev regime not only launched
massive artillery attacks against the
dam in the night of the 6th of June
but it also deliberately
forced the water level of the kakovka
reservoir to a critical level by opening
the valves of the junior prosky
hydroelectric plant
of course we all know full well who it
was who pushed Ukraine along the path of
destruction
by transforming it into a cauldron of
violence
and who it is who supports it also as a
proxy
in the pursuit of a legal Warfare
between inverted commas against Russia
within this very same court
we appear before you today in order to
demonstrate
that Ukraine's application must be
dismissed
because it is without
any Legal Foundation
nor does it have any factual evidence to
back it
in fact
neither the icsft nor the Third
bear any relation
to
the subject of the current disagreements
between the two countries
they are simply being used by Ukraine
and I quote as a means of bringing a
broader set of issues before the court
the artificial nature of this case is
also demonstrated by the fact
that it
includes two factual situations that are
totally different and in fact two
totally separate cases and that is why
as usual we have organized today's oral
arguments in two parts
Mr guzmin
will set out our objections concerning
the icsft
our Council
will then go into more detailed
arguments
after which madame zabalotskaya
will address the Third
and other Council for Russia will go
into the legal and factual arguments
I would now like to ask that you
give the floor to Mr kuzman
I think the agent of the Russian
Federation and I now give the floor to
his Excellency Mr Gennady Guzman agent
of the Russian Federation you have the
floor Excellency
Madam president of the Court it is a
privilege to appear before
you in order to introduce the Russian
federation's case on the icsft
Ukraine's agent said on Tuesday that
Russia is here to pay tribute to
international law
true
Russia respects international law and
the court as a principle judicial body
of the United Nations
but does Ukraine respect the court
apparently not
otherwise Ukraine wouldn't bring to this
court such allegations which have no
basis in law of fact
on Tuesday Council for Ukraine Mr core
said something about a big lie
there are certainly big lies involved
but they come from the Ukrainian side
which continuously attempts to deceive
this court with false and or incomplete
information even our meeting or
distorting its own evidences when it
clearly contradicts Ukraine's claims
the biggest lie coming from Ukraine is
that people fighting for survival are
terrorists
up to the extremely violent cool guitar
and the attempt to kill the legitimate
president of Ukraine who was forced to
free the country
unleashed the brutal Crackdown on all
the centers
culminating the horrible masakena deaths
on 2nd May
2014 when over 50 people were burned
alive by by Dan region
that was not considered an act of
terrorism and has not been effectively
investigated to this day
the east of Ukraine rejected this
hostile origin Keith responded by
launching an armed attack against its
own citizens labeling it an
anti-terrorist operation
the attitude of the made them regime
towards donbass may be summarized by one
quote from Deputy Prime Minister
reznikov he called donbass a mentally
ill territory and the cancerous kimar
that must be cut out
Mr core asked who targeted the civilian
population the response was very simple
it was Ukraine that conducted most of
the shellings in the donbass conflict
this is confirmed by the very reports of
the UN and the other bodies that Ukraine
relies on
the majority of Civilian victims are on
the side controlled by the donbass
Republic shelled and born by
Ukrainian Armed Forces please see
timeline of Ukrainian attacks
in doing so Ukraine used the very same
gravelands merge multiple launch rocket
system and it claims are inherently
indiscriminate weapons
Russia provided an extensive although by
no means exhaustive list of such
incidents in our region
when talking about selling Ukraine
ignores the vast amount of evidence
including from its own side
for instance with regattan reopen
Ukraine never mentions the interrogation
of kirsana who allegedly acted as a spot
for GPR
but deliberately supplied wrong
coordinates of military objectives in
the city
this is confirmed by materials presented
by Ukraine in this court as well as by
the decisions of Ukraine's own courts
and publications of Ukrainian media
Ukraine also constantly downplays the
the fact that it routinely located its
armed forces and residential residential
areas in order to use them as human
Shields
in the case of karmatov Ukraine concedes
the presence of high value military
Target and Ukraine's own expert agrees
that the smirch
multiple launch rocket systems was an i
called Ideal tool for the job
the question only been the range of
deviation of some of the Rockets
considering Ukraine itself routinely
used smearch to attack cities with many
civilian casualties
I never considered a terrorism
at least this is a moot point
Ukraine absolutely claims the Bugis
checkpoint is not a military object even
though its own legislation clearly says
otherwise
as does the presence of military
personal armored vehicles artillery
fortifications and Mine Fields
Ukraine also completely ignores the
evidence that shows how the attack could
have been friendly fire or deliberate
provocation from the Ukrainian side
Mr core also asked who did the United
Nations human rights monitors find other
responsible for a reign of intimidation
and Terror
in fact the very reports that Ukraine
cites clearly state that it was
Ukraine's so-called anti-terrorist
operation that was largely the cause of
I call the climate of insecurity and
fear in Dunvale
the UN monitors say that the civilians
were caught in the crossfire between
cave government forces and the rebels
that accusations of financing of
terrorism against those supporting the
Eastern origin regions are hate speech
and should not be used as a pretext for
persecution
that the Ukrainian security service was
engaged in illegal arrests and false
disappearances of those who opposed
Maidana regime
and that the assistant I quote
communities in the East is a new Civic
spirit that will help Drive the next
phase of the much needed change in
Ukraine
finally the U.N monitors urged all sides
to lay down their arms and engage in a
peace process
which Ukraine stubbornly refused to do
for eight years despite concluding the
means agreements
Mr Cole also asked who just who
destroyed mh17
he seemed to think it is a rhetorical
question but it is not
what Ukraine failed to mention to this
court was the presence and operation of
numerous Ukrainian books in the that was
Zone on conflict on the day of the Amish
17 incident in a direct vicinity of the
crash side
this is proven by the information from
the Netherlands authorities supplied to
the Hague District Court
Ukraine has failed to prove that the
missile which allegedly shut down the
airplane was of a new type
and Russia has proven that this missile
remains of which were allegedly
discovered during the jit investigation
belong to Ukrainian Armed Forces
Ukraine attempts to downplay the fact
that the Ukraine armed forces have
previously already shut down a civilian
airliner killing all 78 people on board
and nobody was accused of terrorism
or even brought to justice for murder
while Ukraine's own president has said
that mistakes happen we are not the
first and not the last
on Tuesday Ukraine even had the audacity
to claim it was a lawful Act
Ukraine's evidence that the alleged book
came from the Russian Federation is
extremely flimsy and replete with Fakes
as we will demonstrate today
on Tuesday Ukraine had nothing to say on
this matter and chose to ignore it
completely
Ukraine has also failed to prove any
kind of terrorist intent with regard to
mh-17
on the contrary even the Hague District
Court which otherwise displayed obvious
bias against the GPR and favorite
Ukraine concluded that there has been no
intent to shoot down a civilian aircraft
and that the book was procured and used
for air defense purposes
the hay Court the Dutch prosecution
and the Jeep agreed that there was no
evidence of terrorism
or of a war crime
Ukraine arguments Ukraine's arguments
hinges on the book allegedly being an
indiscriminate weapon this is an absurd
claim even Prima Fosse since the book is
of course a highly sophisticated
precision-guided weapon system designed
to accurately destroy specific targets
distorts expert reports completely
ignoring the fact that experts agree
that the book tiller does have the
capability to distinguish civil aircraft
from military
and that the tiller was originally
designed to be capable of autonomous
operation
it's the Proclaim that the book had been
legitified at civilian trafficked
Skies
he wants you to turn a blind eye to the
fact that these guys were filled with
Ukraine's own combat aircraft
constantly attacking dpr's position in
bargain GPR cities killing civilians
including women and children
Ukraine chose not to close the airspace
over the zone of conflict
for to civilian traffic
these falls into the pattern of Ukraine
actively using civilians as human shield
to protect its own armed forces from
Rebel attacks
at the end of the day Ukraine's mh-17
case boils down to nonsense
that is that it is lawful and
unintentional for soldiers to shoot down
civilian aircraft by mistake during a
peace time
but unlawful intentional and the
terrorist act to do so during the time
of War
while believing the target to be an
enemy military aircraft
this contradicts not only to the black
letter of the relevant instruments but
also the interpretation of the competent
International bodies
the views of legal Scholars and
extensive State practice
all of which indicates that mistaken
Downing of a civilian aircraft in time
of War negates intent for the purpose of
terrorism or War crime
Ukraine's accusation of Tourism
financing is all the more absurd as
Ukraine itself continue to trade with
dprs and LPR in call still and even
weapons
Mr corset how Russia did nothing to
cooperate with Ukraine
this is a plain pulse
Russia engaged Atlantic correspondence
and consultations with Ukraine with
lasted for years
however it was Ukraine which sabotaged
its own cooperation requests by voting
them by they in vague manner that did
not allow for qualification on the icsft
by rejection of Russia's request for
additional information
and by refusing to provide a list of
requests relating to terrorist financing
Ukraine did not even refer to I icsft in
its
MLA requests
since 2014 Russia received around
thousand MLA requests from Ukraine
and executed almost 800 of them
of these Ukraine selects only 12 as
perfectly related to icsft as evidence
of Russia doing nothing
Ukraine also claims that Russia should
have trusted Ukraine and its claims that
DPR and LPR are terrorist organizations
instead of asking for some objective
evidence of that being the case
today we'll show that there was no basis
for such trust at all
as Ukraine routinely use chunked up
charges of terrorism and its financing
to persecute dissenters and none of the
incidents Ukraine brings to the court
are actually acts of terrorism
finally Ukraine itself has a on multiple
occasions or rejected Russians the
Russians request for legal assistance
including those regarding terrorism
on the grounds of sovereignty
on the grounds of sorry in some cases
for instance
Ukraine openly stated that it did not
trust Russia's qualification of this
organization as terrorists and thus
would not execute the request
the presentation of Russia's case on ICF
on icsft will take place in the
following order
Mr Michael swainston will present
Russia's position on intent and
knowledge as requirements for the
offense of terrorism financing on the
ICS of tea
Professor haryanzari will show how funds
on the icfd do not include weapons
Professor sinhoyi will clarify the
interplay between icsfk and
international humanitarian law in time
of armed conflict
Mr swainsten will return to show how
Ukraine's allegations concern an mh17
has have no basis in law and fact
will demonstrate the same with the
regard to allegations of shelling
bombings and killing
Mr E will return after the lunch break
to show that Russia fully complied with
its obligation and cooperation under
icsfg
and I thank you for your kind attention
and request you madam president to give
the floor to Mr Michael soylstone
I thank the agent of the Russian
Federation and I now invite Mr Michael
Swenson to address the floor
you have the forcer
Madam president
distinguished members of the Court
it is an honor to present to you today
part of Russia's answer to Ukraine's
case under the International Convention
for the suppression of the financing of
terrorism
Ukraine accuses Russia of the serious
offense of terrorist financing
and its trite law that with a serious
offense the accuser must have a clear
case in terms of the elements of the
offense in law and the evidence must be
compelling
Ukraine's case therefore starts on
unpromising ground because generally we
will see that terrorism offenses require
a specific intent such as to injure
civilians for a political purpose
by contrast Ukraine relies on a mistake
a mistake of targeting in relation to
mh17
and Ukraine relies on alleged shellings
and bombings in the course of an armed
conflict
but injury in armed conflict two
civilians is inevitable it does not
point to terrorism
sadly it happens even where scrupulous
efforts are made to follow International
humanitarian law
which regulates conflict
Professor Jen zolin has pointed out the
importance of that distinction between
combatants and terrorists what is at
stake is nothing less than the
distinction between the two it is
imperative to distinguish between
terrorists who deliberately Target
civilians and soldiers who foresee that
civilians will be killed as collateral
damage while striking a military Target
the former is a war crime while the
latter represents lawful conduct and of
course soldiers also make mistakes
so a key issue in these proceedings is
the men's rare required for the
terrorist funding offense under article
2-1
of the icsft
the starting point is what the treaties
say
and hear the ordinary meaning of the
words in context and having regard to
the object and purpose of the treaty
that's our slide four
when we look at article 2-1 of the icsft
it is entirely clear that it creates an
offense requiring specific intention of
the funder to fund terrorist crimes
under article 21A
or terrorist acts under the catch-all
provision in article 2-1 B
Ukraine has cited former Ambassador
marger lato but please see our next
slide slide five
on men's rare Miss lato agrees that
intention is carefully set out and that
specific intent on the part of the
funder is required I quote the
perpetrator must have a specific intent
that the funds will be used to commit
crimes or he or she must at least know
that the funds are to be so used the
construction of the crime is not
self-sufficient but relies on other
instruments
we shall soon see that those other
instruments also require specific intent
on the part of the terrorists who are
funded
as regards the funder the key word is
willfully slide six
Professor ousters explained that
willfully was used to emphasize the
requirement of specific intent in
relation to funding
it doubles up on the subsequent Express
requirements of intention or knowledge
in article 2-1
and it's convenient to look at those
requirements in Article 2 1 B the
catch-all provision for terrorist Acts
because that doesn't depend on the
separate treaties listed in the annex
Article 2 1B sets out requirements of
specific intent at two levels the funder
and the funded terrorists
the funder must provide funds unlawfully
and willfully
with the intention or knowledge that the
people funded will carry out an act
intended
to injure a civilian or non-combatant
and the funder must also know that this
is their intent
and that the terrorists have a special
purpose of intimidating a population or
influencing a government or
International Organization
please note that all of this is specific
direct subject intention
the only concession to objectivity is
the point that special political purpose
can be derived from the nature or
context of the planned Act
in Ukraine's opening submissions there
was an error on this point melon and
Friends focused on special political
purpose
and the objective element there but then
they proceeded as if it applied to all
of the mental elements in article 2-1
and with respect that is obviously wrong
political purpose is the only mental
Criterion where there is a concession to
objectivity on the basis of nature of
the act and context
the rest requires specific intent on the
part of the funder and on the part of
the terrorist
there is significance in the fact that
political purpose was singled out for an
objective test based on the nature and
context of the ACT
it shows that when the state parties
wanted to move away from subjective
intention they did so expressly
Article 2 3 is very informative
and important on the essential aspect of
intent
C slide 10.
it's critical to note that the entire
offense of terrorist financing is
complete when the financing is provided
there is no need for a terrorist defense
or terrorist act to be completed and
indeed there may be none
on the contrary the offensive funding
terrorism is made out precisely because
the funder intends or knows that the
terrorists will carry out a terrorist
act with terrorist intent
in relation to the whole of Article 2 1
A and B Ukraine says it would be odd if
men's rare of the funder requires the
funder to know the mental state of third
parties in other words the funded
terrorists
but with respect that is not odd at all
the whole offense is complete at the
point of financing it depends on the
funders knowledge of the terrorists
terrorist intent it is exactly that
knowledge that makes the funding
dangerous
so Article 2 1 B requires a clear
specific
intention
at the level of the funder and at the
level of the terrorist
the same applies in relation to the
funding of terrorist defenses under
article 21A
article 21A says the funder must intend
or know that one of the crimes in the
listed treaties in the Alex is going to
be committed
this is a requirement for specific
direct intent on the part of the funder
and the funder must know the criminal
intent of the terrorists how otherwise
clearly the funder does not know that a
terrorist defense will be committed
because all of the relevant terrorist
defenses require specific Criminal
Intent on the part of the terrorists
let's start with a Montreal Convention
slide 12.
the offense catches a person who
unlawfully and intentionally destroys an
aircraft in service
that raises the question what kind of
aircraft
the answer
from the plain words in context is clear
first the title of the convention is
convention for the suppression of
unlawful acts against the safety of
civil aviation
the Axton question must be directed
against civil aircraft
the same point flows from the Preamble
which you have at slide 15.
considering that unlawful acts against
the safety of civil aviation jeopardize
the safety of persons and property again
this is unlawful acts directed at a
civil aircraft
in their submissions Milano trends for
Ukraine said the intention to destroy
any aircraft was enough
the word civil was not in the article
but it is in the convention in the title
and in the Preamble and it is the entire
context
article 4-1 puts the matter Beyond doubt
slide 16.
it provides this convention shall not
apply to aircraft used in military
Customs or Police Services
we give the overall result of all this
at slide 17.
the convention creates an offense of
specific intention and the intention
plainly relates to a civil aircraft
there must be a specific intention to
destroy a civil aircraft
now in its reply Ukraine says two things
first
the status of the destroyed aircraft
dictates whether the convention applies
in other words the type of aircraft is a
jurisdictional point we can wait and see
whether the Montreal Convention applies
depending on what kind of aircraft is
shot down
that's their first point
second they say that the status of the
aircraft is not part of intent
but again with respect this is hopeless
we have seen that under Article 2 3 the
offense under the icsft is complete at
the point of financing
there need not be any actual attack
it's therefore impossible to wait for a
tragedy to happen with mistaken
targeting and then retrospectively to
decide that the icsft applies because
retrospectively the shooting down was
within the Montreal Convention
Ukraine proceeds to sight irrelevant to
Authority for the notion that the men's
rare requirements in article 2-1 are
only jurisdictional
Ukraine cites The Tadich case a decision
of the international Tribunal for the
former Yugoslavia
but that tribunal was dealing with
Article 5 of that tribunal's founding
statute which says the international
tribunal shall have the power to
prosecute persons responsible for the
following crimes when committed in armed
conflict and various crimes are then
listed
but that is absolutely not our case
the founding statute did not create
offenses it set out the jurisdiction of
the tribunal with respect to certain
offenses
here the icsft was creating the offense
of terrorist financing it did create
that offense and it did so with clear
Express requirements of specific intent
at the level of the funder and at the
level of the funded terrorists
moreover it's clear in context that this
specific intention covers the civilian
status of the aircraft we've seen that
with the title The Preamble and article
4.
the ilc endorses that view at the
highest level of international legal
analysis and commentary
C slide 19
we cited the commentary on the 1972
draft articles on the prevention and
Punishment of crimes against diplomatic
agents and other internationally
protected persons and the commentary
says the word intentional which is
similar to the requirement found in
Article 1 of the Montreal Convention
have been used to make clear that the
offender must be aware of the status as
an internationally protected person
enjoyed by the victim
so the ilc thought that under the
Montreal Convention intention takes in
the status of the aircraft
there must be an intention to destroy a
civil aircraft the icsft does not cover
mistakes
the point on mistakes also appears from
the travel you see it paragraph 5.1
on the next slide it refers to in some
cases such an act would be inherently
destructive or harmful and intentionally
done and not through inadvertence or
mere negligence would constitute an
offense
this interpretation is also supported by
the teachings of leading jurists which
you can see on slide 22 for example
Professor Trapp the Montreal Convention
requires states to prevent the unlawful
and intentional destruction of a civil
aircraft in service
slide 22.
no one was suggesting that mistakes in
targeting should be treated as terrorism
and there's a broader point no one
suggests that military activities in the
course of armed conflict should be
treated as terrorism on the contrary
Russia's drawn attention to widespread
consensus that the old terrorism
conventions like the icsft do not cover
acting armed conflict and you see that
at slide 22 and as set out in slide 23
we have
icao comment in the icao it's been
widely understood that the Aviation
Security interests that criminalize
certain acts are not applicable to the
military activities they mentioned above
according to the icao that exclusion can
be made clear by Amendment in later
terrorism conventions but when it
happens such a clause would be
considered as declaratory in nature the
reason being there is already an implied
military exclusion
and that appears clearly as well from
the Beijing convention designed to
replace the Montreal Convention Seas
like 24 at article 5-1 we've got an
Express military exclusion like that in
the Montreal Convention at Article 4 we
also have the icao consolidating
amendment at article 6-2 and it says the
activities of armed forces during an
armed conflict as those terms are
understood under International
humanitarian law which are governed by
that law are not governed by this
convention
and the activity is undertaken by
military forces of estate in the excise
of official duties in as much as they
governed by other rules of international
law are not governed by this this
convention
and the same point arises on the Beijing
protocol
Madam president distinguished judges
all of this reflects International
consensus
that bad targeting
especially in the course of armed
conflict is not terrorism
one only has to look at the sadly
growing list of instances where
passenger planes are shot down by
mistake to see that including as we've
heard by Ukraine
none of these instances none has been
regarded as terrorism by the
International Community
and in the USS Vincennes case which
reached this court the United States
made very clear its view that the
convention did not catch military
activities we've set out their
submissions at slides 27 and 28.
foreign
all the indications are that this view
of military exclusion
is generally held
on Tuesday
Ukraine tried to avoid the problem of
past examples of mistaken shooting by
saying that in all of these cases the
shooting was lawful whereas anything
done by the DPR was not
Ukraine relies upon the Judgment of the
Hague Court to say that DPR members did
not have combatant immunity under IHL
but with respect the Hague judgment is
very strange on that point
because the hate Court found that the
conflict in East Ukraine was an
international armed conflict and their
IHL plainly gives combatant immunity
and with respect one must consider the
absurdity of Ukraine's position
it comes to this when a state destroys
an aircraft in peacetime by mistake
is not terrorism under the Montreal
Convention
but when a combatant does so in the heat
and pressure of battle it becomes
terrorism
with respect that makes no sense at all
Ukraine places badly bad Reliance on the
decision of the Hague Court
on the analogy of murder
they point out that the court considers
that if they intends to murder B A
murder C by mistake that's no defense
it's still murder
but there is no analogy with our case in
domestic law a cannot kill b or c
the position is different here under the
icsft where there is an armed conflict
first there is no terrorist intent when
somebody fighting in an armed conflict
makes a mistake
there's no terrorist intent when the
mistake is made in peace time or in
conflict
and secondly there is a general
exclusion of military activities
so that is the Montreal Convention we
need to look quickly at the icstv the
terrorist bombing convention
Ukraine ignores the requirements for
specific intention there again a person
commits an offense within the meaning of
the convention if that person unlawfully
and intentionally delivers an explosive
Etc in a public place Etc with the
intent to cause death or serious bodily
injury or with the intent to cause
extensive destruction
it's clear from Context injury and
damage relate to civilians and civilian
infrastructure
and Ukraine also ignores the exclusion
of military acts in this convention from
the scope of terrorist bombing it's only
concerned with terrorism
we see the references in the title and
Preamble and there's an Express
exclusion of military activities in
article 1902 the activities of armed
forces during armed conflict as those
terms are understood under IHL are not
governed by this convention
so both of the relevant treaties
listed in the annex creating predicate
offenses for terrorist financing
require terrorist intent and they
exclude military activity so how does
Ukraine persist in its case
well first it makes a general point to
cloak its inability to deal with
specific intention it says that if
specific intent is required that the
level of the funder and the funded the
offense will be difficult to prove they
say that's inconsistent with a broad
object and purpose of suppressing
terrorism but with respect that's not
constructive it assumes the conclusion
the offenses created under the icsft and
the listed interventions are very
serious
it's entirely appropriate that they
should depend on proof of serious
Criminal Intent
and next Ukraine says well intention is
not defined so it can introduce
different degrees of intention
but that with respect is not right as
we've seen
Ambassador later observed and explained
for anyone to see the intention is
carefully set out and it's specific and
it's Direct
it's set a specific intent at the level
of the funder and at the level of the
funded funded terrorists the only Point
left to objective assessment is special
political purpose under article 2-1 B
which can be gleaned from nature or
context of the ACT
but that is a single instance and it
shows that when States wanted that they
used expressed words
and that position fits with what we have
on Slide 37.
in other words
other definitions of intent were
considered the United Kingdom said it
should be sufficient if a person
provides funds in circumstances where
there is reasonable suspicion that they
will be used for terrorist purposes
unless the person can prove otherwise
that was rejected
we should also pick up a comment from
the United Nations office on drugs and
crime at slide 38 it addressed how to
draft national law to reflect the icsft
and it made clear that specific
intention or knowledge was required
so when National laws referred to
reasonable cause to suspect it points
out at the end that there could be
problems with requests for international
assistance
last four lines
now Ukraine says it does not rely on the
first limb of article 2-1 intention that
funds are to be used
for terrorist offenses or terrorist acts
intention that they should be used
we see that at slide 39 Ukraine's reply
at footnote 110. instead Ukraine relies
on Russia's purported knowledge
knowledge Madam president members of the
Court turns out to be
alleged knowledge of a risk
which Ukraine says is sufficient to
found dolis eventualis
and that risk is said to come from two
things first in relation to mh17
it comes from the suggestion that a
bhaktila is an indiscriminate weapon
creating a risk for civil aircraft
the second factor is said to be the
notoriety of the DPR as a terrorist
organization from which uh terrorist
acts could be expected you've heard from
Russia's agent that that is an absurd
description of the DPR but both points
are unsustainable
before we turn to them we should note in
parenthesis that Ukraine's cases
confused at this point
Ukraine recognizes that recklessness is
not sufficient see its reply paragraph
109.
recklessness in ordinary English is the
deliberate running of a risk
and then when Ukraine tries to turn
knowledge of risk into intent
sites Italy against abdelaziz slide 42.
that's relied upon for the example of an
attack on a military vehicle in a market
where civilians are present and it's
said by the court that there was a
certainty of serious harm to civilians
and that is said to show that the Act
was motivated by terrorist intent
however
number one this speaks of certainty not
risk there is no analogy with Ukraine's
case here and secondly there is no
consideration of the exclusion of
military activities in armed conflict
but anyway the factual propositions for
uh
knowledge of risk don't stand up
at first
we should note
that Ukraine says
that
the buck was a Russian buck with a
trained Russian crew we have that and
the references at slide 44.
the intercepts relied on at slide 46 the
observations of a journalist slide 47
and The Intercept confirming the arrival
of a bhaktila with a crew at slide 48.
please understand that Russia absolutely
rejects all of this case there was no
Russian Buck no buck came from Russia no
crew for a buck came from Russia and we
will see later that the evidence
propping up this case is unsourced
digital nonsense
but nonetheless for the purpose of legal
argument Ukraine says there was an
experience true and on Ukraine's own
evidence and experienced crew should be
able to distinguish between an airliner
and a military ground attack aircraft
sea slide 50 setting out words of
Ukraine's own expert Dr sporic
an experienced Buck M1 T law commander
and operator can fairly accurately
identify the target based on its
parameters jet engines dimensions and so
on and the court can take judicial
notice that the dimensions in this case
are very very different
Dr storic makes clear that the bhaktila
has an autonomous independent mode
slides 53 and 54 cover that
it has its own radar AR and Tila means
and radar for targeting
Russia's own expert agrees that a
trained crew can identify military
targets and they must do so as part of
the procedure for firing that's the
evidence of Mr Bez barodko at Annex six
to Russia's rejoinder
[Music]
uh he again describes how bhaktilas have
got their own radar the tilar can track
the speed altitude and direction of a
potential Target and see its shape the
crew must assess the target type as part
of the procedure for engaging a Target
and a buck fires a buck Tila fires a
guided missile at a specific Target
which has been identified as a military
one
it absolutely follows the de Buck Tila
is not an indiscriminate weapon an
analogies with nuclear weapons are
precisely irrelevant
on this it's inconsistent with what
Ukraine actually did
the agent for Russia introduced the
document from Netherlands military
intelligence
which was asked whether mh-17 was within
range of a buck when it was destroyed
incidentally it said no and we'll see
that later
the document with English translation is
it slides 57 to 61
the important point to note
from the English translation is that
Ukraine had a baptilar units in theater
and if we can see the table they're
exactly the same bhaktila units as are
attributed in the table at the bottom to
Russia this is covering the whole region
we can also see that these bhaktila
units were operating separately and we
know that because Dr scorik Ukraine's
expert said a complete system includes a
command Unit A targeting unit and six
bhakti laws
these are scattered and separate
we also know that Ukraine issued a notam
setting a level for civil aviation of 32
000 feet where we know that bucks fly
higher than that
how does that fit
what it shows is Ukraine knows full well
that buck tilas operating autonomously
can discrude discriminate they are not
indiscriminate weapons
the crew of a buck is human humans make
mistakes
as Mr presperodka pointed out it's wrong
and please do read his report to say he
said it was inevitable that civilian
aircraft would be shot down what he said
was mistakes happen he also said they
were unavoidable and he said it in the
context of the USS Vincennes but talking
about surface-to-air missiles as a whole
we've heard from the agent how the Dutch
Criminal Court did not find any
terrorist intent on the part of the DPR
to shoot down aircraft and even the jit
ruled out a war crime because of the
absence of specific intent note the
language implausible they did not intend
to kill civilians
there was no basis for anticipating even
on Ukraine's fictional case that a
trained crew would make a mistake just
as in previous instances where mistakes
were made
it's convenient to mention a point on
provision in this context on its
fictional case Ukraine says there was a
Russian back with a Russian crew
the bhakti law belonged to the Russian
army it was under a Russian crew it came
from Russia it returned to Russia that's
nonsense but that's what Ukraine says
none of that involves provision of
anything
the only thing thought to be provided
was air cover against military attack
and air cover is definitely not funds
and it's definitely not any kind of
asset
but I returned to the second way that
Ukraine says that funders in Russia had
knowledge of a risk of terrorist attacks
uh Ukraine talks about the reputation of
the DPR as a terrorist organization
but only crane says that no other state
says it no other International body sees
it
Ukraine relies on a report from the
ohchr to the effect that the DPR
inflicted A Reign of intimidation and
Terror to maintain their position of
control now there are lots of problems
with that that Russia has set out in
writing and please read them but notably
the ohchr was not dealing with terrorism
under the icsft it uses words Terror
often including in relation to Ukraine
and Ukraine's forces
say that the DPR was specifically
targeting civilians with ground-to-air
missiles all with shells all with bombs
on the contrary it was careful to note
that heavy shelling was coming from both
sides and it urged all sides to put down
their arms and engage in dialogue
08 CHR
also did not criticize Aid to the east
it welcomed the assisting of communities
in the east
the points are points are trained
Russian crew on Ukraine's fictional case
extends to this aspect of uh supposed
intention through knowledge of risk
Ukraine talks about the reputation of
the DPR but that's irrelevant if on
Ukraine's case
the bhaktila was in the hands of a
trained Russian crew because whatever
might be said about the reputation of
the DPR and all that has been said is
completely unjustified nobody could
expect a trained Russian crew to make a
mistake and shoot down the civilian
airliner
as we've seen mistakes happen
so on Ukraine's materials
Ukraine has totally failed to show an
intention or knowledge of funding
terrorism
there was nothing that amounts to
intention or knowledge under the icsft
article 2-1 and there was nothing that
qualified as a terrorist defense or
terrorist Act under Article 2 1 a
or 2 1 B
but I would like to make a last point
which meshes with an observation of the
Russian agent I've talked a lot about
the fact that terrorist conventions do
not cover armed conflict and Military
activities
and we've seen the implied and expressed
military exclusions
armed conflict is governed by IHL
and that is outside the jurisdiction of
this court except that it can inform the
interpretation of instruments that are
before the court
the reason for
that lack of jurisdiction compulsory
jurisdiction on IHL
is a practical one
states do not support compulsory
jurisdiction over armed conflict because
in time of on conflict there's a huge
risk of propaganda and there's a real
likelihood that the true facts will be
lost in propaganda or the fog of War
anticipating my later submissions there
is a very great risk that that has
happened here
uh those are my submissions Madam
president I would invite you to give the
floor to hadiyazari who is going to deal
with funds
Mr swainston and I now give the floor to
Professor Hadi Azari you have the floor
professor
thank you very much Madam president
Madam president
distinguished members of the Court
it is a great honor for me to appear
before the highest International
jurisdiction
to represent
some of the aspects of the Russian
federation's response
a significant share of Ukraine's
arguments in particular concerning the
tragic accident of flight mh17 and other
alleged terrorist attacks relies on the
Assumption of the term funds within the
meaning of article 1.1 of the icsft
and this has a very wide scope
which is in fact infinite for Ukraine
the term funds covers and I quote
everything under the sun unquote and I'm
going to demonstrate that this argument
is untenable but I will not take too
much time because the question doesn't
require a lengthy discussion
the term
funds
in Article 1 paragraph one that appears
on the screen is limited to specific
categories of financial assets that have
an intrinsic monetary value
they constitute forms of payment and can
be freely and legally purchased traded
and sold
Ukraine proposes only a partial reading
of this article
it invites us to read only the first
line of the provision and simply ignores
the rest of the provision
and this is not a good faith
interpretation of article one of the
convention
the notion of funds must be read
in the context of the whole provision
and in particular in the light of
specific categories of funds that are
mentioned in it
in other words bank loans Travelers
checks bank checks money orders shares
Securities bonds Bank drafts letter of
letters of credit and documents or
instruments attesting to ownership of
assets or a right over these assets all
these examples refer exclusively to
assets that have three common features
first of all they have an intrinsic
monetary value on their own secondly
their forms of payment and thirdly they
can be freely and legally purchase trade
and sold traded and sold
well these are just examples it is true
but they're all of the same kind
is it insignificant the answer is no
in law nothing is
significant and good faith
interpretation indicates clearly that
the term funds is meant to Encompass
only instruments and financial
securities be they movable or immovable
whose nature is similar to those assets
explicitly enumerated in article one
paragraph one of the convention
purpose of the definition is to cover
items meant to finance the perpetration
of terrorist activities rather than the
items that are themselves used to commit
these very
terrorist acts the title of the
convention expressly refers to
suppression of terrorist financing
Professor Koh
told you that the title means nothing he
is wrong the court considers the title
of a treaty as well to determine its
object and purpose and this is
abundantly Illustrated just to give you
one example in your judgment and
prudentary objectives objections in the
certain Iranian assets case you said and
I will just read the relevant part that
is underlined
the same applies to the object and
purpose of the treaty is set out in the
Preamble and an indication of which can
also be found in the title of the treaty
the word financing or financier
pews at least 14 times in the 1999
convention the word weapon appears zero
times
ammunition appears nowhere
and terms that have a military
connotation never appear and yet Ukraine
is asking you to read them in Article 1
of the convention
but can we seriously imagine that an
issue as sensitive as the regulation of
weapons Supply
to non-state terrorist groups
would be treated as Ukraine contents so
implicitly and be so casually included
in a term that only has a financial and
economic connotation
Madam president
distinguished members of the Court
when
States
decided to focus on a transfer of
weapons in the convention they did so in
an explicit manner there are several
examples of this in our case that is
decided to restrict the scope of the
application to financial support
provided to terrorists however it is the
basic principle of international law
that no one can impose on state
applications that they haven't consented
to themselves so the supply of weapons
would be against the specific
wish of the
States parties to the convention and
this was a very specifically explained
during the travel that was done to when
this convention was adopted and if
France proposed the initial text that
appears on the screen when talking about
the fund they said funds mean any type
of financial resource including the cash
or currency of any State Bank credits
Travelers checks bank checks money
orders shares Securities bonds drafts
letters of credit and any other
negotiable instrument in any form
including electronic or digital form
other states
travel
just to mention one Japan
said funds means any form of pecuniary
benefit
the desire of states to limit this word
to terrorist funding is implicit in the
implementation implementation of the
convention the criminal court of the
Netherlands
said in article 4021 which is on the
screen
a person who deliberately provides
himself
to himself or another with means or
information or deliberately collects
acquires possess or provides another
with objects
Which pull your partly directly
indirectly serve to offer financial
support for Commission of a terrorist
crime
there is no need to underscore that the
object can be movable or
immovable tangible or intangible
but it will only finance terrorism if it
actually serves to offer financial
support for the commission of a
terrorist crime
in according to Dutch law
the word fund should not be understood
in an abstract vacuous manner it is part
of a whole it is a fragment of the text
which is the convention of 1999. in
order to understand it other provisions
of this treaty must be considered
because all of them are articulations of
the same obligation
and in this respect
the preambled
is very important because the object of
the convention is expressly mentioned
the aim is to suppress specifically
funding of terrorist activities rather
than in general suppressing all support
provided to terrorist activities
paragraph seven and paragraph 10 to 13
of the Preamble plus the different
articles of the convention
including articles 8
12.2 Article 13 and article 18 of the
convention
all these articles refer to
financial support provided to terrorism
the icsft specifically aims to dry up
financial support provided to terrorist
organizations and this is confirmed by
the fact that resolution 1373 of the U.N
security Council uh
based on chapters 7 of the charter
almost completely contains essential
elements of the regime constituted by
the 1999 convention and makes the
distinction between terrorist financing
and weapons provision
and they figure in two different
paragraphs the same applies to
resolution 51 2010 of the general
assembly
which is in a paragraph
seven of the Preamble of the convention
team many states have followed the same
approach including Ukraine
for whom weapons and terrorist financing
are treated in two different articles
and separate articles
in the Ukrainian criminal culture
article 258 4
said says
the following as you can see on the
screen
concerning weaponing weapons and article
258.5 concerns financing of terrorism
and
this definitions
use
the first article of icsft and this is
hardly surprising for anyone Madam
president ladies and gentlemen members
of the Court this brings me to the end
of my presentation and I would urge you
to call Professor sienho to the podium
thank you very much
I thank Professor Azari and I now give
the floor to Professor sien hoyi you
have the floor professor
thank you
foreign
president
distinguished members and judges the
court it is a distinct privilege for me
to appear before you today to
participate in the peaceful settlement
dispute before this August institution
and to do so on behalf of the Russian
Federation my task is to clarify
Russia's position on the interplay
between
icsft and international supplementary
law IHL
it is in dispute indisputable and
accepted by both parties that there
existed an armed conflict in the donbass
during the relevant period for purposes
for purposes of this case
that the existence of this armed
conflict triggered the application of
IHL is likewise indisputable this in
turn has significant implications for
the present case for the interpretation
and application of icsfc and conventions
referred to their link contrary to what
Ukraine argues
Ukraine painted a picture of icsfg and
ihls separate and unconnected or in its
own world distinct bodies of
international law on Tuesday Council for
Ukraine argued essentially that there is
no conflict between the two bodies
because only I see sft addresses
financing of terrorism and for this
reason if a less specialist has to be
found to be applied it is icsfg and it
is also the Lex posterior
with respect the council is wrong first
the icsfc and IHL do do not both deal
with financing
they do both deal with defining Terror
second the relationship between the two
bodies of law is also is not subject to
a guessing game as the council play but
has already been specified by article 21
of icsft which the council did not even
mention once not even once article 21
Express provides that
nothing in this convention shall affect
other rights obligations and
responsibilities of states and
individuals on the international law in
particular the purposes of the charter
International humanity and law and other
relevant conventions
this article weaves IHL into icsfd to
form an integral applicable law and
gives priority to IHL
this relationship between icsft and IHL
is that depicted in article
32 of the Vienna convention a lot of
treaties we see our cheat all the
customary role reflected therein the
provision says that when a treaty
specifies that it is subject to or that
it is not to be considered as
incompatible with and earlier or later
treaty the provisions of the other
treaty Prevail the ilc found a number of
treaties contained across in which
parties declare either that the treaty
is not incompatible with or that it is
not to affect the obligations under
another designated treaty they appear in
any case of incompatibility to give
preeminence to the other treaty
this land ioc to propose what has become
vcrt article 32.
this relationship reaches wider than
treaties as article 21 of icsft uses
International humanitarian law to
describe what icsmt is not to affect
this much is confirmed by the travel
paper towel of icsft
this approach follows closely the
nuclear weapons advisor opinion they are
the court decided in principle the iccpr
right not to not arbitrary to be
deprived of one's life applies also in
hostilities the test of what is an
officer the provision of life however
then Falls should be determined by the
applicable like Specialists namely the
law applicable in armed conflict which
is designated is sorry which is designed
to regulate the conduct of hostilities
similarly the security Council has
repeat repeated reaffirm member states
must ensure any measures taken into
counter-terrorism comply with all the
obligations under international law in
particular International humanity and
law
it follows that in a situation of armed
conflict icsfd clearly does not affect
rights obligations and responsibilities
on IHL the ID sft does not and indeed
cannot criminalize conduct that is
lawful under IHL thus the icrc has
declared that instruments aim at
combating terrorism should never Define
those acts as terrorists that are
governed by IHL and not prohibited by it
when committed during armed conflict
such as attacks against military
objectives or military personnel
other Provisions in the icsfg and of the
other treaties relied upon
by Ukraine also confirmed this position
our colleagues have already discussed a
few treaties and which I will not go
into now
our reading is further confirmed by
Article 2 paragraph 1B of icsft which
defines offenses to include any other
act intended to cause death or serious
bodily injury to a civilian or to any
other person not taking an active part
in the hospitalities in a situation of
armed conflict when the purpose of such
act by its nature or context is to
intimidate a population or to compel
organization to do or to abstain from
doing any Act
during the treating negotiations concern
was expressed that a broad definition of
the protected persons will involve
difficulties with application of
humanity and law
and to lead to the situation where
certain ads will be classified as
terrorism when they will be acceptable
under humanitarian law to allevue a such
concern as the counter Memorial points
out the interpretation of icsft
including the interpretation of mental
elements of a terrorist act and Article
2 1B must take place in light and
against the background
of simultaneously applicable and closely
related relevant standards of
international law
article 51 2 of additional protocol 1 of
1977 dealing with International armed
conflict must also be taken into account
provision provides that the civilian
population as such as well as individual
civilians shall not be the object of
attack
Acts or threats of violence the primary
purpose of which is to spread Terror
among the civilian population are
prohibited the exact same language is
also found in article 30 sorry 13 2 of
the additional protocol 2 which is shown
to you on the screen
which I will not read
importance
of intent was emphasized during the
treating equals agents the icrc
commentary on Article 13 2 States
any attack is likely to intimidate the
civilian population the attacks or
threats concern here are those the
primary purpose of which is to spread
Terror as when delegates stated during
the debates at the conference
this rule is considered to reflect
custom international law according to an
icrc study thus the definition of
Article 2 1B of icsft should be read and
Conformity with the criteria for the war
Crime Of Terror under IHL
in a situation of armed conflict only
acts which have spreading Terror as
their primary purpose may fall on
Article 2 1B of icsft and this firmly
excludes incidental or collateral damage
to civilians in fact these were also the
position that Ukraine itself expressed
during the negotiations leading to the
adoption of the additional protocols
Ukraine does not object to these
positions of its own of course
all the Russian Federation description
of them in the academy Memorial
the above reading of article 21 of icsft
and relevant Provisions is supported by
the views of the icrc commentary the
unodc and many scholars expressed in a
variety of contexts or in the judge's
folders for your references
downplaying the role of IHL you as
Ukraine attempts to do will effectively
criminalize or function by non-state
armed groups as terrorism to borrow un
odc's phrasing this would this
incentivize non-state actors from
complying with IHL
since the art being Finance should not
be considered terrorism in the first
place
this will undermine the object and
purpose of icsd effectively rewriting it
to become a convention on the
suppression of General financing of
non-stage groups
in light of the
above analysis IHL is not irrelevant to
the interpretation or application of the
icsft Article 1 weaves IHL into the
convention to form an integral
applicable law and gives priority to ihr
in a situation of armed conflict only
acts which have spread in Terror as
their primary purpose may fall under
Article 2 1B of the icsmt and this
clearly is good incidental or collateral
damage to civilians
I believe this is an auspicious time for
us to take a coffee break if the course
of business I thank you madam president
I thank Professor Yi and indeed before I
invite the next speaker to take the
floor the court will observe a coffee
break of 10 minutes the sitting is
suspended
foreign